uh the commission's climate target plan
for 2013.
it details with great precision
how the eu will reach 55
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions in
10 years time
compared to the 1990 levels um
let me say upfront that this is not
something we do
to save the planet because the planet is
perfectly
well capable to take care of itself it
did so for ages without human beings
being on it
and it could do so for ages if we don't
take care of ourselves this is about
providing a future for humanity
creating a balance between our natural
environment and ourselves
so that we have a sustainable future um
we have conducted as you know
a thorough impact assessment before
presenting this proposal
and um i'm so proud of it i'm so proud
of our services who made this because it
really is it's
it's a big document it will take some
time but i would really encourage you to
read it because it's a balanced document
it doesn't avoid
the difficult issues and it gives you an
idea of what needs to be done and can be
done
so i really want to pay tribute to the
staff
of this organization who have prepared
this
under qadri's guidance we have also
adopted today
a first analysis of the national energy
and climate plans
which were submitted to us by the member
states this is a
really a crucial moment over the next
years
we will spend an enormous amount to
rebuild our economies in response to
this terrible pandemic and the economic
consequence of the pandemic
at the same time we need to continue our
fight against climate change
and steer our societies through an
industrial revolution
all this happening is happening at the
same time by the way
we're also faced with a very very
serious biodiversity grasses
if we get this right if we get this
right
and we get it right now we can
create new jobs and save jobs for
decades to come
and give future generations a healthy
secure
life on this planet um
only two months ago i held my
first grandson looking at this
tiny little baby um i was the
so probably the the happiest pop uh on
earth
but i also worried uh
what sort of world would he live in when
he's when he reaches
20 years of age
he's only two months he can't do very
much himself
and his entire future depends on what
we're doing
his entire future depends on whether we
get it right
now emissions now are not going down
fast enough
and we see the devastating effects of
climate change
every day just take a look at california
oregon
take a look at the droughts that are
affecting all of europe
take a look at the locust infestations
we see in in the east of africa
this is all absolutely linked to climate
change there can be no denying of this
it will not go away it will not just
at some point cool down by itself we
need to act
if we want to prevent the temperature
from rising even more
for this we need to step up our ambition
the new reduction target of
at least 55 percent will give us
and our children the possibility
to find a path to climate neutrality it
provides certainty for investors
and a clear time frame for sectors with
a longer lead time
for their transition if we are serious
about wanting to be um climate neutral
by 2050 we have to start mapping this
out from now from day one
otherwise those who assume that by some
sort of miracle
we would all of a sudden end up with
climate neutrality without doing
anything
are really really misguided so that's
why we're also presenting an amendment
to the proposed european climate law the
new 2030 target of at least 55 percent
needs to be included
as part of our transition to climate
neutrality
by june next year we will present
legislative proposals to deliver
concretely this 55 reduction we will
revise and expand
the eu emissions trading system we'll
adapt the effort sharing regulation and
the framework for land use emissions
will reinforce our energy efficiency and
renewable energy targets
and we will continue to strengthen co2
standards for cars
i will very briefly go into some of
these topics
in our transition to climate neutrality
carbon pricing will continue to play a
key role
the ets is a proven effective tool to
bring down emissions
it gives a strong price signal for green
investments and spurs the market to
develop cost efficient solutions
it also raises revenues that can be used
to address social impacts
or to finance innovation and has been
proven quite resilient even
during this pandemic we will also look
at expanding the ets to road transport
and buildings
emissions trading will be an extra
incentive for change especially in
transport where emissions have steadily
increased over
the past years at the same time we will
need stronger co2 standards for
transport
they guarantee that enough cars clean
cars are available and affordable for
everyone shipping and aviation
are two other big sources of co2
emissions we will continue our work to
bring down aviation emissions inside the
eu
and include shipping in the ets
for sectors outside the ets the effort
sharing regulation sets the necessary
co2 reductions
to keep the right incentives for
reducing emissions in all sectors
and to assure a fair distribution we
will review it
together with ets finally
the land used land change and forestry
sector needs to step up too
it absorbs co2 but a landsink has been
shrinking
to reach climate neutrality and preserve
biodiversity
the sink has to grow back to previous
levels and we really have to take care
of our forests
it's not enough just to say we'll plant
three billion trees we need to make sure
our forests stay healthy and this is
going to be a momentous task
this is how we'll deliver our target i
know it's ambitious
but we plan to achieve the same
reductions in this decade
as we have over the past 25 years
i'm confident this can be done we have
the policies we have the commitment
we have the funds to support it
but fairness is key our ambition should
help not hurt
the most vulnerable in society this
transition will be just or there will be
no transition
we have to act in time so we can still
manage the transition
that is why it is important that we
start now no time to waste
the world's eyes are upon us every
signatory
to the paris agreement needs to update
its national determined contribution
this year
our first target was an important
benchmark we can again set the
bar for the rest of the world to follow
only this morning
secretary general guterres made a very
strong plea to the european union to
stick to this
and to show also on a national level
that we can do this
let's make this a race to the top so
that everybody wins
kari over to you so you can go into the
energy related aspects of today's
package thank you france
to match the challenges of the century
we need both
long-term vision and uh immediate action
and we cannot wait until 2050
is at the doorstep act on climate
totality
as if we are cramming for an exam at
last moment
and we cannot leave the responsibility
and consequences
of climate change to the next
generations so
the climate target plan we present today
is not just a plan
to cut emissions faster and cheaper
it is also a plan for transforming the
way we produce
consume and transport energy across all
sectors
of our economy the energy sector has a
key role to play in achieving that
55 reduction in greenhouse gases
as it is um accounting for 75 percent of
eu emissions
and by 2030 electrification needs to
reach
30 percent the rate of building
renovation has to double
the share of renewables in transport
needs to reach
around 24 percent and oil consumption
has to go down by almost a third
and gas consumption by a quarter so we
know that each of these mean
massive change but our careful
assessment
shows that it is doable europe's power
generation sector is already
the most decarbonized in the world and
now we
need to focus on transforming all
sectors
transport and buildings in particular
and more than a third of emissions come
from buildings
especially their heating and cooling and
there is a huge potential in improving
the energy efficiency of houses
so this is why in less than a month the
commission will come out
with a renovation wave initiative in the
transport sector
we need to tackle every angle
strengthening the co2 standards for
vehicles
making clean fuels such as hydrogen more
accessible
investing heavily in infrastructure and
deploying smart traffic management
system
and my good colleague adina valen is
working on the sustainable and smart
mobility strategy that will cover all
these
stands of work and together with the
climate plan the college adopted
the assessment of the national election
climate plans today
so i want to thank all the member states
for their efforts
over two years each of them now
has a forward-looking blueprint for
clean energy transformation
and investment and our assessment of
those plans
shows that based on existing policies
we will overachieve our current 2030
greenhouse gas reduction target
of at least 40 percent the picture is
especially encouraging when we look at
renewables
we are global technological leaders and
the price of renewable energy in europe
is
steadily falling the nsp
assessment projects that we are on track
to produce more than 33 percent of our
energy
from renewable resources these existing
policies
so this is beyond the current 2030
target of at least
32 percent and we are going to build on
that success
and also the market momentum by coming
out with uh
offshore and energy strategy later this
year
the eu is also moving away from coal the
majority of the member states have
either already phased out goal or set a
specific deadline
for doing so and by 2030
the use of gold would decrease by 70
percent
today we also gave a further push to
clean energy
the commission adopted the eu renewable
energy financing mechanism
that allows countries where producing
renewable energy is challenging
to pool resources and invest in member
states with abundant wind and sun
then saps also reveal where where
there are crater challenges and for
example in
energy efficiency there is still a gap
of about
three percent to reach our current
target of 32.5 percent
but there is also new interest in the
topic and our renovation wave
eco design and energy efficiency first
initiatives will help us
to use that momentum there are still
40 million europeans that struggle to
keep their homes
warm during heating period and this is
unacceptable
while renovation can reduce energy bills
the policies have to be designed in a
way that makes it also possible for the
less privileged
to take the advantage of them and we
will provide guidance to the member
states
this year on addressing nih politics
the national plans were of course
prepared with the current 2030
target in mind and to reach the 55
percent goal
we will need to do more so the impact
assessment force is the need for a
38 to 40 percent share of renewables in
our energy mix
and 36 to 39
improvement in our energy efficiency
in the climate target plan we commit to
reviewing
the renewable energy and energy
efficiency directives
including the targets by next june
a change of this magnitude requires
serious investment
an additional 350 billion euros
per year and then as the peace will have
a crucial role to play here
as they will provide input for the
recovery and resilience plans and
just transition plans of the member
states
and i encourage all eu countries take
advantage of the
unprecedented funding opportunities
available under the next generation
eu and the long-term eu paycheck
and i'm happy to see that member states
from france to lithuania
have already made clean investment a
central part of the recovery strategy
many of the choices we need to take
are tough moving from 40 to 55
doesn't just mean changing a figure on
the paper
it means real impact on people and
businesses
but we have the will the technology
and the resources and still enough time
to become climate neutral by 2050 and
every year the eu gives away
50 billion euros in the form of fossil
fuel subsidies
this is roughly the same amount of money
we invest annually in wind and solar
energy and energy infrastructure
so this is one example of where we need
to rethink
and reset but europe has proved time and
again
that we are capable of doing just that
thank you
thank you commissioner and thank you as
well executive vice president i'm
reliably
informed that all of our press materials
are now published
online for you um i'll also just remind
you that after this press conference we
will also have
a technical briefing off the record on
these files
um but of course i would like to pass
over now to your questions
for the executive vice president and for
the commissioner the first hand that i
see
raised is matisse uh skiffers over to
you matisse
hi this is from headfinisher.
i have two questions for commissioner
timmermans
you have requested for this impact
assessment this
extensive impact assessment and i was
wondering has it given any new insights
to you both
positive or negative is there anything
that took you
by surprise and another question is
about um
the plan to for to increase the linear
reduction of outstanding emission rights
it's now 2.2 percent um where should it
go do we
should we think about the doubling of
this percentage can you
elaborate a little bit on that thank you
on your first question it really is
as i said fascinating reading and in
some areas
um it gives me more optimism
especially the um the industrial
transformation
appears to be more feasible than i had
anticipated if i look at the
at the impact assessment in other areas
i really i really need us to focus
uh on the possible negative consequences
especially for households
and citizens so that we make sure that
we leave no one behind which means
that we have to have special attention
for things such as the risk of energy
poverty such as the risk of
uh unequal distribution of the burdens
within our society so that also came out
of the impact assessment so some some
surprisingly uh positive news and some
also a bit worrying
where i think as policy makers and as
politicians
we need to really really focus on
preventing this becoming
as something that hurts part of our
population already our population
is um unevenly struck by things like the
pandemic
of course the virus doesn't discriminate
but the effects of the virus
are completely different in a situation
where you're in a vulnerable situation
because of your health or because of
your
socio-economic situation or because of
the job you have etc
and this applies to tackling the climate
crisis as well so i think this is
something
i would also draw your attention to when
you read the impact assessment
that puts the finger on that and that
gives us an opportunity also
to address it and to avoid those those
problems
on your second question i don't think
we're ready to answer that yet we still
need to
study it um so i can't give you a
percentage
okay um i will take the next question
another dutch
question and sander van horn please
so sanders disappeared
he needs to press speak
ah here i am um one question
in english um do you think that in the
end
the um country reports will uh
function as some kind of like what we
see in the budgets that
there will be some kind of internal
naming and shaming if countries don't
meet their target and will that help
them to keep them focused
the second question will be in dutch
sorry
colleagues i have to do this um
[Music]
yes if i can comment the national
ancient climate plans as you know
well the targets both on energy
efficiency and renewables are unique for
each and every member state
because the starting positions are
different and energy mix that member
states are using are different ones too
this is a right of each and every member
state to decide
what kind of um anatomics they do use
if we are talking about um overachievers
or those who are lagging behind then we
are comparing them
with their own plans um with their draft
plans
and after the floral negotiations
many member states raised their targets
already last year
before they provided us their final
plans those
ncps are giving us unique tool because
now we know
what the member states are planning to
do on renewable sites
and this also helps them to prepare the
recovery and resilience plans
so yes we are monitoring closely that
everything that that was promised will
be fulfilled
but no naming and shaming but we will
take each and every member state
as they are with their unique energy mix
over the last factor
okay thank you the next hand that i had
raised is david
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
economic
and the second question on on the vote
yesterday by the european parliament
on the just transition fund the
parliament
asked to to include gas projects
in in the financing of the uh
just transition fund in certain cases i
know but
it's always gas what do you think about
it is it
coherent with the with the the target
and
all the philosophy of the green deal
thank you
you'll answer the second question um
[Music]
[Music]
that that this is very important that
we need public support our ambitious
plan to become climate neutral
without public support and acceptance it
is possible to
impossible to achieve at the same time
that clean transition doesn't mean
necessarily a higher price for
end consumers for example a renovation
wave
will bring comfortable temperatures
and better living conditions
lower pills because after renovating um
well badly um
iso insulated buildings you consume
less energy um
moving towards more electrification
means also that we will use our own
electricity and renewable electricity
prices have come down
and that helps us to avoid very volatile
oil prices
that are right now with cheap price
but we have seen volatility in previous
years
um about just transition funds well
so far we have achieved our climate
targets
mainly because the transition in energy
sector so
many member states have phase out coal
faster than they
initially planned um at the same time we
know that
regions that have been dependent on
mining for
past decades they also tend to well heat
their districts the district heating is
um
is coming from excess heat of all plants
and that's why the um
question if you will phase out coal as a
source
for energy power plant where will you
get your
[Music]
district heating then
this is a topic where we should really
negotiate this european parliament and
regions
how we can help renovating district
heating systems
and if the natural gas or later on
decarbonized gas
is the most feasible option or
for example using also partly solid
biomass
can can produce
produce the same same benefits
thank you thank you commissioner next
hand raised is carolina from
thank you commissioners um i have a
question for mr timmermans
in the recent days there has been a
debate on whether or not to include
things in the determination of how much
emissions are actually reduced
because they were not counted in the old
target so to say
and critics fear to include them now
will dilute the goals could you please
comment on that
thank you our goal is to get to -55
by 2030 which will smooth the path to
climate neutrality
by 2050 and of course we include
in that on the basis also of the recent
most recent
findings of unfc triple unf triple c
carbon sink of course if you want to
create enthusiasm with the european
population that you're going to plant
three billion trees that you're going to
look after the sustainability of our
forests who really really need our
attention because they're in bad shape
if you do all of that the compensation
for that effort is going to be carbon
sink and that is a positive
effect on attaining our targets
uh the the target is what counts uh we
use every method
to get there we are not um
you could wonder why we didn't include
it in the in the minus 40 at the time
because carbon sink is an important
uh element in in all of this
and uh finally i think it's also
very important um to to understand
that if you find the right combination
here you not only
create more carbon sink you also address
one of the other existential threats we
have
which is the loss of biodiversity so
focusing on forestry creating uh healthy
forests
and planting three billion uh trees
is on all sides a huge contribution to
getting us
where we need to go i do understand
that in some ngos environmental and
jewels
there is a worry that we would not reach
that goal but if you look at our
impact assessment you can see that it's
realistic that we can
achieve it i also understand and i saw
it this
morning again in a tweet by wwf
that they would rather have us
have a higher goal of minus 65 percent i
understand their position and it's
very good that they keep us on our toes
but i think
the way we have calculated it in our
impact assessment
brings us to -55 in 2030 which sets us
really on a course
to be a climate neutral by 2050
but i encourage all the ngos to keep us
on our toes
to keep us sharp and to criticize us if
they believe we're not doing it right
but i'm happy to explain why i believe
i think we're doing this exactly right
thank you very much
uh la president prochaine questions uber
so i'm going to pass on next question
and we'll come back to you in a moment
i'll give the floor to ah
there's no mic anna i'm afraid i'll pass
the floor on to frederick seymour and
we'll try and come back to anna in a
moment
federic yes can you hear me
yes thanks yes thanks all right uh
this is actually a question on on the
previous one
about carbon removals and carbon sinks
can you explain how you've you've
calculated
this because the current targets for
2030 and the achievement of those
targets
are do not take into account
carbon sinks so you're making an
adjustment
to the way the achievement of the
targets are being calculated
uh so can you explain how that uh works
and uh when it comes to the the
criticism
of including carbon sinks some of the
ngos have said that if you do that
then you look you're no longer in effect
talking about a 55
reduction but more like 50
can you maybe confirm or
those figures or say whether you came up
to a different conclusion
in your impact assessment well once
again
i know that their starting position is
probably that they want us to do minus
65
and i think you need to keep that that
in mind when you look at these
things uh we have uh come to the
conclusion that 65
for for a number of reasons is simply
not feasible
um and i believe um we should not
i mean we need to take actual
responsibility given the level of
development
of the european union but we should not
be in this alone and we
we should be able to address other
industrialized nations to also take
their part of the responsibility that's
one of the reasons why we stick to the
-55
secondly if you look at the logic
and this the methods applied by unf
triple c
they all include carbon sink it's the
latest knowledge
applicable to these calculations and
this is exactly what we have done
at the european commission so i think
we're on on solid ground here
to get us to minus 55 and let me remind
you of this
our target is to get to -55
by 2030 and this helps us do it and i
i i am deeply convinced that carbon sink
needs to be an important part of this
it also creates i think enthusiasm in
the population and alliance with the
population and it also forces us
to look at the health of our natural
environment in europe whether it's
forests and biodiversity
and all this combined strongly um
encourages me to continue along this
path this is not
i i really dispute the idea that this
would in
fact mean only a 50
reduction what you do then with carbon
sink is that then all of a sudden
something you don't calculate anymore
doesn't that play a role i don't
understand the logic carbon sink plays a
role it takes away
co2 out of the atmosphere isn't that
what we want to achieve
and at the end of the day the only thing
that counts is will this take us to -55
we say yes so that's where we need to go
and i honestly believe there's no
problem with that
thank you very much of course fred we're
happy to go into that in a little bit
more technical detail if you like uh
afterwards
in the follow-up briefing um the next
person i have in the list is
asking for the floor is daffy dabiago
press speak tap it
hello hey we hear you
go ahead okay great um so in the impact
assessment and you mentioned it in your
speech is that gas
will go down is it 13 to 19 percent
so my question is given the political
difficulties with russia
do we still need nordstrom 2
and then more generally do we still need
more investments in gas
was daffodil at the midday briefing
uh i'm not sure if he was connected uh
well i think i think
uh mr mahmer has answered this question
five times
something like that so i'll just refer
to his answer and not repeat that okay
very good the next person i had with the
hand raised was
thomas friedrich
thomas you need to press speak
yes yes yes okay now here
thomas waitress for german engineers the
paper for the nation vice president you
mentioned
that the european forces are in bad
shape and
carbon zinc is at risk what does it mean
concretely
in terms of biodiversity
and linked to agriculture farm to fork
strategy do you intend to revise
as well the figures which are on the
table up to now
concerning agriculture thank you well we
are preparing our forestry uh strategy
which is going to be
in sync with farm to fork and with our
biodiversity strategy the two
uh documents that have already been uh
presented um and i i believe that um you
know all the information i get
from member states and studying the
issue myself is that it is
urgent uh to address this issue but it's
at the same time also a huge opportunity
for rural areas and our farming
a community um creating the possibility
for our farming community to be
increasingly
shepherds of our natural environment and
and protectors of our biodiversity
is something we really need to look at
and we need to modernize a number of
things we need to bring broadband
to all rural areas in europe we need to
give the
agriculture communities the instruments
to act in here
but the but the positive results both in
terms of biodiversity
positives carbon sink
positives and economic opportunity as
well
is such that this investment is really
something
that will pay off so i'm afraid
that you i will have to ask for a bit of
your patience until our forestry
strategy is ready but it will be in sync
with what we've already announced in the
biodiversity strategy and the farm to
fork strategy
okay let's try again with anna i believe
your microphone is connected now
[Music]
[Music]
you've muted yourself you've done too
many conference calls
she's not the only one
nina can you unmute yourself but we'll
come back to you in a minute
okay let's move on then to ever eva
krukowska from bloomberg
uh hello can you hear me yes
that's great i have actually two
questions one to vice president
uh timmer manson went to commissioner
simpson uh
to vice president timmermans um i had a
very quick look at the impact assessment
and basically it shows that uh the pace
of emission reductions
in the ets sectors would be much faster
under the new
2030 goal than in sectors outside the
market
with carbon prices near record highs
companies are going increasingly worried
that without
enough protection they will either go
bankrupt or
they will have to relocate i know that
the commission is planning carbon border
adjustment mechanism but it will take
time
what would be a message to companies
that are overly worried or just
concerned about
uh carbon prices and and future
increases
and to commissioner simpson um something
that is linked
to the renovation wave that you are
planning
and what president van der lyon said
yesterday
she signaled that europe should consider
setting up
a uh european bauhaus how would you see
that and why is that important thank you
on your first uh question um you know
we're going to have to
increase the functioning of the ets it
is a big success come on
you know i'm i'm really surprised i
thought it would take a much bigger hit
in in the covet uh period but it didn't
it was really resilient and it came out
even stronger
and so we need to make sure we we
enlarge that we need to make sure we
bring new sectors in
we need to make sure that we reduce uh
free allowances but we can only do that
if we create a level playing field also
on a global scale and for that
we need a carbon border adjustment
mechanism as also president from the
lion said very clearly
in the state of the union yesterday and
we're working very hard on that
why are we working so hard on that
because it has to be
it has to be very very precise this has
to be
laser precise because if you if you get
it wrong and you
you apply it to sectors that don't need
it or the wrong sectors
you create unnecessary turmoil also
internationally you have to make sure
that you're yet that you're surgical in
assessing which sectors in europe are
unduly affected by the fact
that other parts of the world do not
take steps to comply
with the paris agreements and on that
you will have to introduce carbon border
adjustment
let me also state very clearly that
both in the ets and non-ets sectors an
overwhelming majority of companies
are urging us to continue along these
lines and to work towards climate
neutrality what they're asking of us is
predictability
and certainty over a long period of time
and that's what we need to offer and i
believe
ets is a perfect instrument for that
also in light of the fact that ets is
becoming a global phenomenon
you know china is going to introduce its
ets systems and you see it
in other parts of the world happening
everywhere
and you know in this in this new
environment we're in
we used to only price in other factors
capital and labor
we need to price in carbon as a factor
in
the way our society functions and our
economy works and ets is the best way to
do this
also on a global scale so i'm really
really enthusiastic
about this and i think we can we can
really
move forward quite fast and i believe
this is to the benefit
of european industry of course in
certain areas of the industry
uh this will be quite a heavy burden
because they need they know they need to
invest but they need to invest anyway
they need to restructure anyway
and and i i don't believe there is a
future in europe
for gray steel but there is a cr
incredible future in europe for green
steel
and the the fastest week the faster we
can get there and ets is an important
instrument that
calm border adjustment is an important
instrument that steel made by hydrogen
i mean then europe has a big winner that
will have
global impacts these are the things we
need to do and i i i'm more than willing
to address certain specific issues with
parts of the industry
my colleagues and i we we did deep dives
in in in most
parts of the european industry we know
there's a huge need for restructuring
everywhere and for investment
we stand ready to be part of that and we
know that also that
member states stand ready to do this and
you will see this also when
the plans will be announced for the
recovery uh
coming i think before the 15th of
october
commissioner on the renovation yes
well we know that the cheapest nhm is
the nature that we don't use and that's
why nhf isn't efficiency first principle
is still so valid and right now 40
percent
of our emissions is coming from building
sectors of mainly
heating and cooling and um and there are
worse performing buildings
that have been built um decades ago
at the same time all across europe we
have good examples
that if you renovate for example
um multi-apartment buildings that were
built in 80s in
the eastern part of europe then after
renovation
the heating costs are coming
significantly down
so our initiative that we will present
after
four weeks will will address
those barriers that avoid us so far
to reach the numbers that
we aim for so specifically we would like
to double
the renovation rates all across europe
and this is um
very important also in this angle that
it creates jobs for
construction sector and and it also
creates
jobs for them for the industry
that provides materials for construction
so at the same time when we're we're
going to renovate
old building stock hospitals schools
kindergartens and and social housing
will be our primary target we know that
all across europe um
still new buildings are built and good
architecture and good
and energy efficient design this is a
key
if we want to people that accept the
embrace of change
so so this was the message
that let's create the style and
architecture of our time
architecture that that helps our cities
to become cleaner and
and also reconnect us with nature and
and this kind of um
wave of new buildings
um helps us um to achieve
both our climate targets and then energy
efficiency targets
and also um um
makes our environment
more enjoyable thank you can i just add
one thing on bar
because because i'm a great fan of
bauhaus
architecture i like the reference
because bahas was not just about
designing and building
beautiful houses it was also about
democratizing the accessibility of
livable
environments it was about creating
affordable
and still artistic
furniture housing lighting
um the organization of urban
areas this was a huge democratization
movement and
emancipation movement
so it was not just about designing
beautiful buildings
it was about creating a natural and
natural habitat for everyone not just
beautiful things for people who can
afford it but beautiful things
for everyone and bringing society to a
higher level that's why
bauhaus was such a beautiful initiative
that will
withstand the times
and that's also why all the autocrats
coming to power in europe
in the 1920s and the 30s attacked
bauhaus
and tried to make it disappear so it's i
think if you
make a reference to bauhaus it also has
a strong
political connotation that's why i liked
it so much thank you
let's try again and connect with kalina
from politico
can you hear me now yes yes perfect
terribly sorry for that i wish i could
pretend that i should have
i should have known better i'm just like
competent on this issue
and anyway to the um vice president mr
timmermans i was wondering on the
question of expanding admissions trading
um have you changed your opinion on
extending the system to
to road transport because i think only
last week at a conference with transport
environment
you had said that you actually weren't
convinced of the idea um
to cover cars in the ets and
um and so i was just wondering if you
could elaborate on
your views and what might have changed
it and and the second question to come
back to the
issue of forests um has there been
any calculations done on the potential
risks of relying on forests especially
given
forest fires i mean i do understand the
reliance on things however
with climate impacts we're covering ever
more frequent forests themselves
becoming more vulnerable to going up in
flames which in itself
could undermine eu climate goals thank
you on your first question i've never
i've never made a secret of my
skepticism in terms of bringing road
transport under ets
but since we are technologically neutral
at the commission i am open to being
convinced if the study
uh would show that this is an efficient
way of doing it i think
if you look over the past uh decades
what has been effective in terms of
regulation is
um emissions that has worked really well
to bring
emissions down you know to just to set
standards for emissions
um ets let's let's have a good look at
it
in transport the commission is strongly
committed to that
uh but i think i should be honest by
saying that i'm personally rather
skeptical but i will also be very open
if i can be convinced that this is
something that could work
i also say this with a bit of a
reference to my previous job in the
commission which was about better
regulation
we have to be careful that this is not
something that creates
huge administrative uh burdens if you
want to implement it and
and and this is one of the paradoxes i
see some of the people i see
strongly advocating this are also the
people who are strongly advocating the
reduction of administrative burden so we
have to make sure
we strike the right uh balance here but
i'm open to it
uh albeit being skeptical and i think i
should not make a secret of that
as far as carbon sink is concerned well
there are
you know this is not this is not
something you can
you can uh script like a script in a
play or
or a movie uh you will always have to
react
to external events whether it's forest
fires whether it's
certain global uh developments in the
economy and industry
the the thing what we can do is to make
an impact assessment on the basis of the
best available
information we have today and that's
what we've done also in terms
of um carbon sink um but
you know you can have four sides but you
can also have certain developments in
certain sectors of the industry in the
energy sector etc
that would also have an impact on
whether we could reach the -55 and then
we will have to adapt
you know we will have to adapt and
that's why
clearly the impact assessment is not
written for the ages it's a starting
point
and whenever we make proposals in
different sectors we will have to do an
impact assessment for that sector
on the base of the information we have
then but you cannot this is not
something you can a script like a play
or or a movie
thank you uh we're getting to the point
now where i'm gonna have to start
disappointing people because we only
have a few minutes uh
if the commissioners with us and i see a
lot of hands still raised
i'll go now to olivier lebruce if olivia
can keep it short i think we can take
one more afterwards
and if you can find the speak button
over here
olivier we don't hear you and i'm not
quite sure why so i'm going to move on
in the interest of time sorry about that
i'm going to take lorenzo console now
please
can you hear me yes and see you hello
yes okay uh it's it's a very simple
question yesterday
president fondo lyon has uh uh mentioned
uh the vision of uh hydrogen valleys
uh in europe uh and she also mentioned
this uh
example in sweden where uh there is this
pilot project for green uh steel
uh vice president timmermans has
mentioned that as well
just now uh my question is
how will these hydrogen valleys will
be what is can you tell us
more about this vision uh and and if i
made this
green eye green steel project seem to be
still
quite far away they are starting now
there's a i had about 2025.
is it not too late uh
is it not too much time that we had to
wait for to see
uh green steel produced are
at a an economy uh mass economy level
thanks
well kadri and i are both extremely
enthusiastic about
our hydrogen alliance you know just
20 to 24 that's just down the road it's
just a couple of years
we will have six gigawatts of
electrolysis in europe
um and perhaps we would even be
surprised more because
this is really picking up this was
something of a niche thing only a year
ago and now
everywhere in europe this has been seen
as one of the
key elements of creating a sustainable
energy source
of creating energy renewable energy
storage
of using existing and adapting existing
infrastructure
foreign carbon neutral energy facility
etc
um recently you also
saw the french government making
announcements there and it will be part
of the franco
german discussion as well so
really this is taking off like a rocket
no pun intended
um and i honestly believe
you know look at your country and i've
mentioned this many times before as you
know
i know the city of taranto and we know
that the city
is uh you know it's it's to quote good
it has uh two souls
in its chest one is the economic
activity that is necessary
and the other is the devastation to the
environment caused by that economic
activity
just imagine you can solve that
conundrum by bringing green steel to
target
just imagine you can do that you can
create
a a very healthy natural environment and
a very healthy
economic environment and yes you are
right this is not going to happen
tomorrow
so national authorities together with us
together with the steel sector
we'll have to see how we get the steel
sector to that point
using uh enhancing our investment in
developing of technology
using the time also to upscale this
technology
helping the steel sector overcome the
first couple of years in difficulty
protecting
the steel sector against undue
competition from other parts of the
world
so that they have a level playing field
and yes we will need to invest also
public money into this transitional
period but i believe
i cannot imagine a european economy and
industry without steel
but i also don't believe that grey steel
has much of a chance in europe in the
future but green steel
could be euros contribution to changing
uh the steel
fabric of the of of the world's economy
because once you get green steel going
everybody will want to have green steel
and
if you're the first to do that i'm sure
you'll have huge economic benefits for
that and just imagine
in your own country what this could do
for tarato
commissioner anything you'd like to add
on hydrogen perhaps but if i
just connect that in the end of this
year we will also review that any
regulation
so that we can address the problem how
hydrogen can transport it from where it
is produced
to where it the end users are locating
and and one of the options is
retrofitting existing pipelines gas
pipelines
another one is dedicated infrastructure
we will also address
the storing question because um clean
hydrogen is a very useful tool
if we are um keeping in mind the
progress that is going on for offshore
wind
parks and it helps us to store the
green electricity at the moment when
there is no demand
but we do have good wind windy and um
days and and um
for us it is um clear that to achieve
our climate targets
we need to reach um
to the end in situation where
while end users are using renewable
fuels there are some sectors
that can't use electricity it is either
too expensive or impossible
and hydration green hydrogen is a very
good
solution for them not only steel but
also cement
some parts of them transport so
we just launched the hydrogen strategy
and
and there are specific national
hydrogen plants all across europe so um
would you see that also many member
states will propose
as part of the recurrent resilience
plans investments
into the reduction of hydrogen thank you
thank you it's okay with you both i'll
give olivier a second chance to connect
okay and then we'll have to call it
today and we'll take the other questions
in the technical briefing
olivier second chance
it seems we're still struggling we'll
try for third time lucky in the
technical briefing olivier
um on that note i'm gonna call it to a
close i'm sorry to those who didn't get
a chance to answer your question
to ask your questions directly to the
vice president and to the commissioner
but as i say we'll be back back in a
couple of minutes if you just allow me
to accompany
um them off the stage and we'll start
the technical briefing in a few minutes
thank you very much executive vice
president
thank you commissioner thanks a lot
so
you